Lynne is with us in Canada hi Lynne how
are you good Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up I'm part of a
blended family and I've been married for
one year
and I've been together for almost three
years my husband wants a paper divorce
to get financial aid for his kids you've
got to be kidding
you've got to be kidding me no that's
absolutely absurd no I'm not divorcing
my wife so I can get welfare well the
thing is you're really gonna argue with
me about this aren't you well I don't
want the kids to be disadvantaged
because of my assets but when they're
not disadvantaged because of your assets
they're disadvantaged we're not going to
give them welfare oh well like I don't
believe in out of state education I
believe like if it's a grad school
professional like medical dental or law
or something yeah maybe I'll fund that
give them a loan but no they don't need
to be on debt they don't need to be in
debt to their stepmother either this is
also a bad plan so if you know if you if
you feel so inclined to pay for your
step children's education after one year
of marriage that would be a gift and it
would be unusual okay what would that
gift should be it'd be a gift if you
didn't know I mean if you give them a
dollar if you give them a hundred
thousand dollars it would be a gift
what is your asset base it's about 3.2
okay and what is his he's broke two
hundred two hundred thousand dollars and
he wants to do a paper divorce so his
kids qualify for welfare education well
he makes about a hundred she
be ashamed of himself I mean he makes on
to honey makes 180 200 a year he makes
it he's got 200 makes a hundred a year
what do you make I make a boat 400 350
Canadian how many children are involved
four how old are they 17 15 13 11 months
young wonder pine and did they think
that he married a gravy train are they
ungrateful and entitled I don't know
what they think oh so you've not had
conversations with them I feel I would
help them out as much as I would help my
own but I don't believe in Otis state
education I believe in I agree
possibility my children went to in-state
school and all four of all three of them
are successful and so did I and you know
my parents helped out with some but it's
not just mmm so here's the deal here's
the deal
if you want to help you it is your money
you have the right to set the terms but
I feel that because of my asset they
couldn't get their loan if that was what
they don't want them to get along and if
they want to commit financial suicide
that's their planet yes
but because of my assets they can't they
won't qualify oh darn
so you're you being married to him as
presenting them preventing them in
Canada from getting a loan no it's
actually we just live across the border
from each other so we're just like two
hours away and because of Canadian taxes
and because of the businesses I own he
was supposed to move up to Canada but
due to some medical problems of his
daughter he isn't and and you know so I
we really haven't even lived together as
a married couple but on
you know we know how to arrange this is
starting to sound it is and it's been
really hard yeah be very very careful
darling you've not been married but a
year you've not even combined your
households yet and you're already up
with your sweetheart for paying for
these kids education I'm not like I'm
fine contributing some yeah some but
very little and that's only and listen I
only contribute when they do stuff the
way I say do it because I have their
best interest in Hart not because I'm a
control freak but I don't fund people's
stupidity I don't participate in their
insanity and you shouldn't either that's
not an act of love that is an act of
enabling and you are in a wicked weird
situation you need to be using very
careful because there's a reasonable
probability that you have a mess on your
hands I mean a roof Wow
scary scary scary hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]